哈喽大家好，今天不是一期vlog
今天是一个big shirt
你们觉得这个是游戏吗？不不不，这是我哥给我做的我的世界工作台
你只需要三步就可以让ai帮你做出来一个像这样的工作台
那这个工作台呢，就是用来记录我暑假的学习和生活的
那首先就让我来介绍一下我的工作台长什么样子吧
嗯，这是我的工作台，然后左边是一页导航栏
这上面是学习生活和家务模块啊
这三个模块是让我通过工作学习来赚取这些经验的下面
还有我最喜欢的三个模块，就是小卖部世界和背包模块
那让我们一起来看一下这三个模块是长什么样的吧
首先是这个世界板块，我用ai打造了一个我的世界的游戏场景
像这些是移动也可以按w，A,S,D,这里就是跳
往后走。这些功能都能的
接下来这里还有一系列我挖过，并且我背包里面有的东西
还可以下矿打怪，如果死了没或者没血了还这里还会有提示，这是我们的小卖部模块
这这里会显示一些我们可能在平常玩我的世界时所需要用的原料
而这里就是我们合成之后的铁镐，石斧石剑，钻石剑这些东西，第三个就是背包是
跟我的世界里面同款的一些格子里面存放的一些物品，比如说石镐
木棍石头木剑还有钻石剑
这些什么你害怕孩子自己玩儿工作还没事儿，这可是有家长锁的屁股
现场锁顾名思义就是你点一下它就可以上锁，这样孩子就再也动不了里面的东西了
什么？你说你刚才没有在我的工作台里面看到这个家长锁吗？那是因为这其实是我弟的
工作台，那么以上就是我工作台的分享啦
那么如果你也感兴趣的话，你在评论区交出你的工作台吧，那么下个视频再见喽，拜拜